BE THERE, AND FORTUNATBUT HE SEE
HAAN, THE ONE  OFFICIAL AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT HIS ARM UP.
>> Pat: ETS HIS STICK ON THE
PUCK AND THE BLACKHAWKS ARE
ABLE TO GET A LITTLE
POSSESSION ON ddie: THE SECOND R
PLAY UNIT COMES OU GIVE AND GO
WITH KURASHEV.
WENT TO THE GOAL LINE
WITHSTROME TO SHOOT IT,
SOMETHING HAPPEN. ING TO TRY
COZENS DROPPED IT BACK.
JOKIHARJU ONON FROM DOT TO
DOT, IT'S GOING TO BE
>> PatE.
WATCH THIS PLAY.
SKINNER HAS IT, HE'LL .
DROPS IT BACK, GOOD SAVE BY
LANKINEN!
TAKEN BYSABRES WITHIN ONE! HITSE
UNFORTUNATELY.
THE PUCK IS LYING THERE,
THEN MCCABE.
AT HIS BACK TOKANE, THE QUICK
LITTLE SHO
DRAW.
COZENS TURNS IT AROUND. .  KATC
GOING ATOFFSON WILL TEE IT
UP, IN AND
THE SABRES ARE GOING TO WIN!
TAGE THO